claude blanchemaison bonsoir merci
d'être en direct avec nous sur rt france
a alors qu'est ce que vous retenez du
discours en ligne de svetlana tirs à 9
ce qu'aia devant l'assemblée nationale
ben je crois d'abord qu'on peut dire que
ça sur l'intervention prêterait bien
préparées à l'avancé et surtout les
réponses qu'elle a faite aux différents
députés de la commission les affaires
étrangères montrent qu'elles étaient
sérieuses
articulé voire même déterminé alors elle
a indiqué que l'objectif c'était
d'obtenir de nouvelles directions en
biélorussie mais des élections libres et
équitables et elle a articulé 3-3-3
manière dans sa stratégie
d'abord il faut il faut effectivement
négocié avec le système at elle dit dans
son esprit pour écarter monsieur le cas
de chico et ensuite avoir des élections
plus tard alors monsieur loukachenko
aujourd'hui a confirmé semble-t-il qu'il
était disposé à revoir la constitution
toute la question sera de savoir avec
qui discutera de ses révisions
constitutionnelles
madame
d'ikanos kaya a par ailleurs répondu aux
questions plus posé les députés et
notamment quand ils lui ont demandé
comment peut-on vous aider elle a
répondu de manière assez précise
elle à dire d'abord en faisant des
voyages en biélorussie que les députés
français et européens viennent voir par
eux-mêmes
quelle est la situation et on voit mal
que le gouvernement biélorusse puisse
s'y opposer
et puis elle a proposé des choses très
concrètes
elle a dit par exemple que la pologne
avait commencé à prodiguer des veines
médicale aux gens qui étaient arrêtés et
elle a parlé de corridors humanitaires
pour ces aides médicales qui pourraient
être amplifiées de la part des pays de
l'union européenne elle a aussi parlé de
l'accueil des étudiants étudiants dont
certains ont été renvoyés de leur
université parce qu'ils manifestaient et
effectivement dans ce cas là pourrait-il
être accueillis dans des universités de
pays de l'union européenne elle a aussi
parlé de fonds de solidarité pour venir
en aide aux prisonniers politiques ou à
leur famille ou pour venir en aide à des
employés qui auraient été licenciés par
les entreprises publiques qui commence
et représente à peu près 75 % de
l'économie biélorusse donc pour une fois
elle a été assez concrète dans ses
propositions
et effectivement elle a reçu un accueil
plutôt sympathique de la part de ses
députés de la commission des affaires
étrangères de l'assemblée nationale
alors pourquoi aujourd'hui l'opposante
biélorusse a t'elle l'oreille de paris
et de berlin
or parce qu'elle représente l'image de
la la liberté la liberté d'expression de
la liberté de manifestation des droits
de l'homme des élections libres et que
dans des pays comme l'allemagne comme la
france s'il ya un écho dans les médias
et dans la population en plus du côté
français ça fait peut-être penser au
tableau de delacroix la liberté guidant
le peuple
enfin c'est une autre époque et d'autres
circonstances bien sûr mais c'est vrai
qu'elle a cette image et que en plus
c'est un combat de femmes puisque ce
sont magnifiques majoritairement des
femmes qui manifestent et notamment le
samedi il ya une manifestation de femmes
dans les grandes villes deviennent
russie
donc tous ces éléments font que
effectivement il y a un regard
bienveillant de la part des populations
en allemagne et en france
alors le président alexandre loukachenko
doit-il à craindre
ils essaient d'ignorer ils essaient
l'ignorait mais c'est compliqué parce
qu'il ne peut pas complètement ignoré
les manifestants on ignorait
complètement les sanctions d'ailleurs
madame tia a demandé un élan un
allongement de la liste des individus se
met à sanction incidemment elle est
toujours hostile à des sanctions
économiques donc il n'y a pas de
sanctions économiques et il n'y aura pas
de sanction économique car effectivement
elle s'appliquerait plus tôt à la
population qu'aux dirigeants la
biélorussie sont des sanctions
personnelles
donc je pense que monsieur loukachenko
est relativement tranquille dans la
mesure où ils contrôlent parfaitement
ses organes de sécurité police et armée
qui a pratiquement pas de défection et
qu' il peut aussi contrôler par le biais
des entreprises publiques
là où les ouvriers qui avaient commencé
à se mettre en grève
il ya quelques semaines donc il n'a pas
à être inquiet à court terme
simplement on voit aussi que lorsqu'ils
étaient reçus par monsieur poutine
monsieur poutine lui a dû au fait et la
réforme de la constitution dont vous
aviez parlé il ya quelques semaines
c'est pour quand et c'est pour ça qu'il
a repris cette idée aujourd'hui monsieur
loukachenko il se sent donc obligés de
faire quelque chose il ne peut pas ne
rien faire et ce quelque chose c'est
probablement en effet dans son esprit
une réforme de la constitution qui peut
être libre à livrer un peu les
institutions et donnerait plus de
pouvoir à son gouvernement qui
permettrait aussi de faire des élections
libres simplement là il ya un petit
problème qui est que madame chicanos
callas ne veut pas discuter de la
constitution avec monsieur loukachenko
et qu'il faudra sans doute trouver un
arrangement
on notera que les sanctions européennes
et sanctions individuelles ne touchent
pas monsieur kachin kio personnellement
puisque monsieur macron considère qu il
y a encore des marges de négociation et
je pense que madame merkel le pense
aussi
avec le fc eux est sans doute possible
de discuter autre monsieur loukachenko
et l'opposition de la conduite et des
conditions dans lesquelles la
constitution pourrait être révisée et
des conditions dans lesquelles des
élections pourraient être organisées à
terme dans des conditions acceptables
par tout le monde
donc monsieur loukachenko est condamné à
vivre de façon un peu un commode avec
cette opposition un peu bruyante
peut-être pas directement avec madame
chicanos callas puisque elle est à
l'étranger et qu'il est probable que il
a laissé sera pas rentré de sitôt en
biélorussie merci beaucoup
claude blanchemaison je rappelle que
vous êtes expert en relations
internationales